today on Chalk radio teaching about
sustainability in a sustainable way
when we think about education of a
different kind it's not that what we're
doing is all wrong and bad but it's that
we could be doing things better and we
could be finding ways to embrace
sustainability through a ton of
different Avenues in our classrooms
I'm Sarah Hansen for this episode I sat
down with two Educators from mit's
Environmental Solutions initiative these
Educators helped create open resources
for bringing sustainability into the
classroom
my name is Sarah Myers and I'm the
education program manager at ESI my name
is Liz Potter Nelson and I just finished
up as a postdoctoral associate in
environmental and sustainability
education with ESI
can you just tell us a little bit about
what the Environmental Solutions
initiative is
absolutely
ESI is really mit's effort to mobilize
the knowledge and research and education
Across The Institute so that it doesn't
belong in any one Department many of the
problems that we see in sustainability
are interdisciplinary problems and you
need people from different disciplines
coming together to work together to
solve things so ESI is really mit's
effort to Leverage The Best of the Best
from across the University
climate change and environmental
challenges are huge problems with
massive implications that affect all of
us in different ways while working
together at ESI Sarah and Liz spent a
lot of time thinking about how to
address the broad spectrum of issues
that climate change and environmental
disruption pose through the lens of
sustainability
so before delving into the details here
let's first get clear on something what
even is sustainability first of all if
you ask that question to a hundred
different people you'll get 200
different answers as far as I can tell
so technically sustainable development
is defined in the brentland report from
1987 as development that meets the needs
of the present without compromising the
ability of future generations to meet
their own needs that is a very
anthropocentric statement I think it
doesn't include things like other
species or things like the environment
itself but even if we just start with
that it is very very broad
it isn't just recycling it is not just
turning off your lights it is not just
climate change if you look right now at
the sustainable development goals of the
UN there are 17 of them they include
things like education and women's rights
and no poverty and partnership between
institutions it's very broadly defined
you cannot imagine a future without
understanding the human behavior without
understanding the impact of what we have
already done to this planet the impact
of histories and culture to a people you
can't just walk in somewhere and say
we're going to change the planet
both Sarah and Liz spent
nature and Liz as a high school science
teacher they both became interested in
sustainability through different lenses
which really brought home their point
about sustainability being fundamentally
interdisciplinary
building from Sarah's explanation about
sustainability where we're looking at
solving Wicked problems that are
connected socially economically
environmentally sustainability Scholars
and sustainability education is really
looking at how to create people who are
sustainability illiterate there are
people who have the knowledge skills and
dispositions to live sustainably
I've been in education for a while but
this term sustainability education was
new for me what a lot of people are
arguing in the literature is that our
current education Systems Support
unsustainable behaviors and so really
when we start to think about education
we're thinking of Education that now
starts to promote sustainability it
starts to as Sarah mentioned not only
look at our current needs as people but
needs of future Generations this can
happen in a lot of different ways it
could be as an instructor finding ways
that you increase the conversations
around sustainability in your classroom
so it could be talking more about carbon
capture and different sustainability
ideas talking more about the science and
sustainability or the social impacts of
making decisions it could also start by
looking at how you are teaching and
finding ways that you can Embrace
student-centered Active Learning in the
way that you're teaching a lot of the
literature is starting to say that it's
not just talking about sustainability
that some important and teaching
students about sustainability that's
important but it's how you're actually
modeling and teaching that within the
classroom there are ways that
fundamentally when we start to unpack
things within the education system there
are parts of it that are oppressive to
certain people there are parts that are
we have a colonialized education system
in its foundation and so if we really
start to get at the root of
sustainability it starts to also call
into questions some of those systemic
things that are preventing people from
accessing that education or living their
culture within our education system so
when we think about education of a
different kind it's not that what we're
doing is all wrong and bad but it's that
we could be doing things better and we
could be finding ways to embrace
sustainability through a ton of
different Avenues in our classrooms
to help teachers bring sustainability
into their classrooms no matter what
subject they teach or what levels Sarah
and Liz created the sustainability and
climate change across learning
environments project also called scales
the sustainability and climate change
across learning environments project
scales is meant to leverage all of the
resources from across MIT classes and
provide them to teachers wherever they
are wherever they may be and they can
use them as open source so they can use
them as they like they can adapt them
and a deeper level where we'd like to
see this go is that it actually becomes
a repository and a resource for teachers
not just for MIT curriculum but for any
of this kind of curriculum that might be
similarly related and so we went back to
the ocw archives was the first place we
looked at classes that we knew had
climate or sustainability content to say
can we make this publicly available for
teachers
so this is actual problem sets and
lecture notes and ideas but then to give
a little bit more support like Liz was
saying you know well how do I teach this
like what does it mean to teach with
sustainability
any classroom teacher that you talk to
has heard that they should be using
Active Learning or student-centered
learning or using groups or
participatory learning so it's not
necessarily new but it's really kind of
connecting now those fields of education
and best practices in education with
sustainability so that hopefully we can
start to address some of you know the
larger sustainability questions and
problems in the world knowing that
climate change is real and how do we
start preparing students and generations
to start tackling those problems
scales incorporate six pedagogical
practices each is meant to Foster this
multi-disciplinary holistic approach to
sustainability education
there are so many great ideas for
educators to consider incorporating into
their teaching here's a quick breakdown
first there's collaborative small group
learning students work together in
groups of two to roughly six students to
solve a problem together
then there's inquiry-based learning
students are starting to ask questions
and work to answer their questions
experiential learning things like going
on field trips having guest speakers in
doing internships other types of
Hands-On learning experiences Service
Learning where you have students who are
engaging with their community and
providing a service experience within
that Community place-based Learning
place-based learning often has students
going out into the community and
learning about their place learning
about the geographical place that
they're in their local community
government and finally culturally
sustained learning culturally sustained
learning starts to really look at how
students are able to embrace their
cultures within the education system
it's built off of culturally responsive
and culturally relevant learning and so
the idea in this is that teachers are
finding ways within their curriculum to
let students not only Embrace their
culture but then also expand on their
culture and so culturally sustained
learning has been kind of building those
things like hip-hop pedagogy that fall
under it but for me a lot of the way
that I see this presented in the
materials that we've looked at is really
in teaching practices and how we help
students recognize their own unique
cultures and help them start to advocate
for themselves in their education
setting
along with these pedagogical practices
scales also outlines competency areas
that Define sustainability literacy
these are things like systems thinking
social justice active citizenship and
Futures thinking I love Futures thinking
because it doesn't happen very often in
our classes but it's this idea of what
does this look like in the future for
future generations and when I say it
doesn't happen a lot in our classrooms
what I really mean is in Western Society
it doesn't happen a lot in our
classrooms we don't often think about
what the impacts of what we're doing
will be for Our grandchildren's
Generation than their children and so
that I think is really an interesting
thing to do and there's some really fun
and unique visioning activities that you
can do where you can say you know let's
let's revision our downtown and what
does that start to look like but it
starts to really help people see how
their choices have impacts in the future
just like thinking about teachers you've
both been teachers like
you know it is a ton of work just to
even like set up a classroom and arrange
the desks and you know create a grading
system and communicate with parents make
sure kids have lunch and food and you
know and then they're like I cannot add
like one more thing to my to-do list
like what is your response to them
so the goal isn't to throw out what
you're doing but it's to make small
changes to what you are doing so that
that way you can start to embrace
sustainability I used to be a former
chemistry teacher so maybe you have a
problem set and you have some random
chemical equation maybe you put in the
chemical equation for smog for that one
instead and start to Loop things like
that in then maybe the next change you
make the next year is that instead of
just having that chemical equation for
smog in there you and students are doing
their calculation they get you know
something about carbon dioxide out of it
it's starting to draw these little
changes and connections it's not
throwing everything out it's not
intentionally trying to add one more
thing in it's recognizing the good that
you're doing and then finding small
places to make it even better
teachers are lifelong Learners they
really are it's not like you learn to
teach and then you're like all right
I'll do this for 40 years like teachers
continuously go back for professional
development to improve their craft
forever like even mastered teachers this
just Builds on that we're not saying you
can no longer teach chemistry it's that
we know that students are going to be
more engaged when they see real world
connections so let's figure out a way to
do more of that and to do that better so
it's not replacing what you do but it's
enhancing what you do and and to me this
makes perfect sense if you're a teacher
who's still teaching the exact same
thing in the exact same way 10 15 years
later you're probably bored you probably
want something different
um and that's it's supposed to be a way
in
if you're a regular listener to our
podcast you'll know how much we at ocw
love it when teachers use our materials
and remix them for use in their own
classrooms that's one of the main
reasons we exist and when Sarah and Liz
created scales we were so excited to
share this with the world part of what
we love about it is that it's really
designed to make that process of
remixing as easy as possible they did
this specifically by providing open
resources from across mit's curriculum
in adaptable and editable formats so
that's going to make it really easy for
you to use these materials we'll end the
episode today with some advice for
instructors who want to incorporate
scales or other ocw materials into their
classrooms the biggest thing is trust
yourself as an instructor these are some
really awesome materials and tools that
worked for an instructor but now it's
figuring out how to make them work for
you so it could be something that you
could immediately give to your students
or it might be something that you might
need to give them a little bit more
background information on or something
that you might want to take a little bit
further most of the material is geared
at the undergraduate level so it might
be something that if you are working
with a freshman or sophomore in high
school that you might need to provide
some more scaffolding to or adjust the
assignment just a little bit the other
piece of that is you as the instructor
know your students academically and
emotionally some of the topics can be a
little bit heavy for some of your high
school students or even some of your
college students and so I think even
putting on that lens of talking about
climate can can trigger strong emotions
in everybody and so just making sure
that as you work to remix them that
you're also cognizant that you're
providing those supports because you as
the instructor have an awesome wealth of
knowledge and you can easily use these
you just need to trust yourself and and
go with it
if you're interested in teaching with
the scales materials you'll find them on
our MIT opencourseware website you can
also go right to
scales.mit.edu you can follow Sarah
Myers and her work at the MIT
Environmental Solutions initiative
website
Liz Potter Nelson is now an assistant
professor of physics and Science
Education at the University of Maine at
Farmington you can follow her work there
I'll share all these links with you in
the show notes
thank you so much for listening until
next time signing off from Cambridge
Massachusetts I'm your host Sarah Hansen
from MIT opencourseware
MIT chalk radio's producers include
myself Brett patchy and Dave leshansky
the show notes for this episode were
written by Peter Chipman the scales
offering on MIT open courseware was
published by Alicia Frankie be sure to
give us a follow on Instagram Twitter
and wherever you get your podcasts
foreign